hi my name is keanu i'm a tasty producer
and today i want to show you how to be a
better baker
[Music]
pies are such a fun simple way to be
creative you have a crust and you fill
it with generally fruit that has a
little bit of sugar a little bit of
spice so you kind of have a blank canvas
to decorate it however you want you
don't have to be a professional to do it
pie decorating can be as simple or as
complicated as you want it to be even if
you don't have proper tools you can use
the most random items in your kitchen
when you're trying to customize and like
make your pie look like your own you
really can use anything that's available
to you use whatever tools you have in
your kitchen to customize and make it
your own i think the fun thing about
baking is that most desserts have
different components so when you're
cooking with other people everyone can
kind of take charge of a section of that
so if you're making a pie one person can
tackle the crust maybe another person
can tackle the filling for example my
sister is into spices so she will read
the cabin and put a little bit of this a
little bit of that in there so i can pay
more attention to making the crust so
you're in the kitchen you're baking
together but everyone has a piece they
can put their own personal flair and
personality too and they'll all get
baked together into like one cool little
product but everyone had their hands in
it i haven't lived in my hometown in
over 10 years so anytime i go back home
my family immediately requests a pie for
me it doesn't matter if it's a holiday
they're like we want apple pie period
even though they're asking for the exact
same thing time after time again it's a
fun creative challenge of how do i take
the exact same ingredients but make it
new where everyone is still like whoa
we've never seen that before customizing
decoration is a huge part of it there's
so many ways of transforming a familiar
dish so that excitement never fades very
few people in my family bake even to
this day when i return home for any
holiday i am working with bare minimum
equipment when i'm cooking with my
family i am always trying to get
creative and make desserts with what we
already have so i'm like how can i make
dessert for this dinner without
cluttering the family kitchen with
things that they aren't going to use all
the time it's so easy to
say i want to get into baking and then
buy all of this stuff but really you can
make dessert with a lot fewer things
than you need you can get creative with
what you already have around the house
there's so many ways you can present
your dish and it doesn't always have to
be exactly as a recipe told you i've
always viewed a recipe as a piece of
inspiration or kind of an overview
guideline of what to do but then the
real joy of home cooking is that it's
your kitchen it's your rules you can do
what you want if it says put one
teaspoon of cinnamon and you don't like
cinnamon put something else in there
there's a lot of room to customize and
make your desserts a lot more creative
and unique which is what people are
going to respond to when you put in
front of them because it's going to be
different from what you can buy from
your grocery store and you have more
control over what you're making and can
make it fit to the occasion better
there's this whole world of how you
visually present what you're making that
really can transition you into a whole
different realm of challenging like what
the tried and true is and you can really
get creative so a dessert that i made
that was more of a challenge was making
a charlotte royale it is a old school
english cake when i'm making stuff at
home i want to make things that i want
to eat that means seeing this really
classic recipe but switching out the
parts that i wish i could have it as i
could never buy so with the charlotte
royal i made i am a huge fan of
cheesecake it is one of my favorite
types of dessert and i decided to fill
the charlotte royal with cheesecake
instead of bavarian cream because i
think what you're making should excite
you so even though it was by the book
one way when you're cooking for yourself
and for your friends you want to make it
tailored to your audience and make it
how you're going to enjoy it cake making
has a lot more moving parts that can go
a little bit more wrong once you know
what makes a great cake batter what
makes a great icing you can start
playing around with how you present that
and you can change the shape and
decorate it really cool and pretty with
anything practice makes perfect so when
you're making that batter you want to
make sure at no point are you over
working that batter a big mistake you
can make is wanting to have the batter
look nice and smooth and like luxurious
where to make a really great cake batter
you want it to be just combined so that
everything is there otherwise if you're
overworking it you're actually going to
make a really tough cake it's always
great having that moment where you put
that thing you spent all afternoon
making on a table in front of people and
getting that wow reaction you want to
see people excited
to make a beautiful dessert it's not
about doing the most complicated thing
the recipe itself can be very simple
it's how you customize it and stylize it
just by putting your own personality
into it and getting creative with cake
making you generally have multiple
components and to make sure in the end
you end up with a beautiful cake you
really have to pay attention to every
element and take your time you're never
being too over ambitious with any stuff
so if there is a part that you're maybe
not as comfortable with take a shortcut
make it simpler you don't need every
element of what you're doing to be brand
new to you so to make something
different that people may have not seen
before i decided to
do this rippled ombre effect borrowing
inspiration from another type of cake
called zebra cake each color pushes out
the previous creating this nice ripple
effect but instead of having two colors
back and forth with tiny quantities i
decided to do four shades of brown to
white so it took something that people
were very familiar with chocolate
cheesecake snow bake and whip it up in
10 minutes and through customizing it
turn it into a very beautiful and unique
dessert
[Music]
there's so many things that can go wrong
while baking you can crack the
cheesecake or maybe you forgot to spray
your cake and it will not come out the
pan or you over baked your cookies and
they are hard as a brick don't worry
about it you can salvage it and get a
little creative to make something new
and still have a really great dessert in
the end
i think it's really important to know
that just because something didn't turn
out as you intended does not mean it's
always a lost cause you can always
repurpose what you've already made and
make another really cool dessert out of
it or sometimes you can even fix it and
cover up your mistake when looking at a
recipe to make the first thing you do is
figure out what part of science and what
part is flavor the science i'm not
messing with i'm not messing with how
it's going to rise or structurally work
but with the flavor that's when it
becomes customizable when you're making
things in your own kitchen your
imagination has no limit you can put
whatever ingredients you want you can
make it shaped however you want it
really is a reflection of your
personality or what you did that day
like if you went to the farmer's market
and saw beautiful strawberries you're
going to use that and it's putting a lot
more of yourself into the food than
you'd actually expect it too
baking is inherently a celebratory food
every occasion we have in life usually
has an accompanied dessert it's
generally for something or for someone
and i think there's nothing more awkward
or fearful than putting something in
front of someone that you're like hey
i'm expecting you to eat this and in
their mind they're like oh i don't want
to eat that how can i pretend that i
like it it's always a goal to put
something in front of people that
they're like genuinely excited to try
when you're baking for other people when
you present it to them there's so much
appreciation that comes into that even
though it might not be perfect every
time especially when you're starting to
bake out but when you take time and
effort to make things for the people
that you care about it does not go
unnoticed and you have a secondary
reward that you get to make things for
people but then after that you get to
share it with them as well and you get
to sit down with your friends down with
your family over the food you've just
made for them enjoy each other's company
have the laughs blow out the candles and
just have a good time
even when you're baking yes stuff can go
wrong it might not be exactly as you
envisioned it and it can't be perfect
all the time but when you're baking for
other people they're going to appreciate
that you took the time put the energy
into making something really special for
them and that's always nice to share
food with other people that you care
about oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you